Planned Parenthood has suffered massive
layoffs you're fired less than two weeks
before the anniversary of decision in
Dobbs to overrule Roe v Wade it's two
weeks before according to the Boston
Globe more than 100 employees of planned
parenthood's National staff received
notice that they would lose their jobs
why are they losing their jobs is it
because donations to Planned Parenthood
dried up no donations to Planned
Parenthood spiked after Dobbs that was a
major historic fundraising opportunity
for Planned Parenthood they took
advantage of it every big live in the
country was saying give your money to
Planned Parenthood so they had the money
but demand cratered they no longer had
the customers this is a great story
because it proves something that
conservatives did not believe for far
too long which is that culture is
Downstream of politics because the law
is a teacher